I can remember as a kid growing up I
would have these dreams I didn't know
what sport I was playing I would just
see myself in a stadium full of people
cheering for me
[Applause]
it gave me a sense of man there's
something out there for me and it wasn't
a moment like man so cool I wish I could
be able to do that it was a moment like
oh that's cool
I definitely can do that
the first time I ever ran I felt so free
I felt like a little kid again like
nothing mattered and you know the fact I
was disabled it had no value all the
trials and tribulations and the
challenges that I faced as a kid had no
value the only thing that mattered in
that moment was how fast I was running
that's why I trained because when I'm
out there I put my blades on and I'm
running and competing I feel free God
put me on this earth to be the fastest
man in the world to compete at the
highest level dad's walking for
[Music]
it was the day I was born
and they rushed me out to rushing out
the room and the doctor came back to the
room and sit down my mom and dad and
then he looked at my dad kissing
Vishal Ebert I know you wanted to be a
coach I'm sorry but he might not be able
to walk he might not be able to run jump
and play like the rest of the kids that
was a conversation that my parents had
to have from day one because you're born
without legs it sucks but you have to
work harder than everybody else in the
classroom on the basketball court you
have to be above average
[Music]
growing up I can remember playing sports
and people knew my situation and knew
that the fact that I was missing my legs
so I'll run run run and never fall off I
just learned to kind of just work with
that and it's like okay if my leg falls
off pick it back up kind of taught me
how to get back up so I really like when
you fall down you got to get back up and
I literally physically had to learn to
get myself back up with what I had so I
went to college and that's what I've
seen
Oscar Pistorius the top blade runner in
the world on TV and I like that's it
that's what I was dreaming that moment
sparked something great in me it gave me
hope it gave me a sense of there's
something out there for me how long as I
could run a train hard I think I'd be
able to get to the level that he is I
got my first pair of running blades back
in 2009-2010 and my first race ever I
beat everybody the coach comes over and
says congratulations you just qualified
to the Paralympic team I think about
that moment and thinking about all the
sacrifices and the moments that it took
to get to the Paralympic Games and
competing at the highest level and
taking the silver LeBron that's why all
right
competing against able-bodied runners
leafless hoping to get to the 2020
Olympics to compete against able-bodied
athletes but it's currently battling the
IAAF the sport's governing body which
says his blades give him an advantage we
per determined to change that rule in
your short just my goal is to beat one
of the fascism in the world to be
qualifying for the Olympic Games against
able-bodied competitors I'm training six
seven days a week for this one moment
and I tell you what I do have an
advantage but it's not my legs my
advantage is my mindset right I was born
less than from day one I've had to work
hard my whole life how to get back up
easy every time I had to give up hundred
twenty percent of every practice that's
my advantage
because I know life isn't fair I'm gonna
fight I'm fighting for every disabled
person that's being discriminated
against in
[Music]
and show them that if you believe a
dream to have a goal and being truly
believe it you can achieve it
[Music]